it's about 4 a.m
it's um so we've been here since 1 53
a.m
it is july 3rd 2021.
we are in north america morocco we are
on the interstate 95
near uh exit 57.4
it was just bizarre now this weekend 11
heavily armed men
wearing tactical gear and claiming
exemption from u.s
law and state law shut down part of a
massachusetts interstate
during a traffic stop well they say
they're part of a group that calls
themselves
the rise of the moors and say they were
on their way to
quote training well the entire ordeal
that it ended after an
eight hour long standoff with police and
for reference
the capitol breach lasted about three
hours
now some of the members were arraigned
yesterday in what became a pretty
chaotic hearing
how can i get a problem
i'm not guilty
[Music]
i'm not hispanic i'm not latino american
i
am well within my constitutionally
secured rights to carry and bear arms as
the more national
laws because you don't have weapons we
carry arms
it's a reasonable question to ask why
isn't this being covered
by the media and what else do we need to
know about them well joining me now are
two men who know these types
well todd mcgee former massachusetts
state trooper
and chris wecker former fbi assistant
director todd now
you know this group i've never heard of
this group before but you know them well
from your time as a state trooper up
there now what can you tell us
well i think we first need to point back
to sovereign citizen ideology
and what's important about sovereign
citizen ideology
is recognizing the recruitment tools and
the propaganda that's used by
the rise of the moors and other moorish
groups such as this
and they will point to things such as
the treaty dating back to
1777 i've also seen dates of 1787
which was a treaty between the united
states and the moroccan in the country
of morocco
well what that treaty was about was
about
maritime laws for maritime that allowed
privilege
of the united states and the privileges
for the moroccan
country their maritime to support
privileges
based on economic not treaties for
citizens
but economic reasons just like sovereign
citizens will also use
maritime laws in order to confuse law
enforcement during motor vehicle stops
so we have to understand that they don't
recognize themselves as sovereign
citizens
however their ideology is closely
aligned to sovereign citizen ideology
well it's very bizarre well chris here's
what one of the men
said about their supposed rights
with the right to having no tags
no licenses or no legislation
chris again i think most people are just
shocked by this also shocked but maybe
not all that shocked that the media
gave it a pretty much of a big yawn over
the weekend
again what do americans need to
understand about this
yeah these these groups emerged in the
90s different iterations of the moorish
nation
sovereign nation what have you i dealt
with them when i was the head of the fbi
in north carolina
they don't recognize any authority
whatsoever
but they're basically a criminal
organization or a set of criminal
organizations that wrap themselves in
some convoluted political ideology
basically to justify committing crimes
and the crimes they commit
they're prolific fraudsters they'll take
over someone's home
file quit cane claim deeds and then move
into the home while they're not there
they commit tax fraud false tax returns
they've killed over a dozen police
officers since 2002
in particular in baton rouge louisiana
of
one individual one morse nation
individual killed three officers and
moved to three others
so they present a clear and present
danger to law enforcement
and no but nobody should take them
lightly they aren't they aren't some you
know
some benign political organization
that's just a facade
and todd another member uh spoke about
what they claimed were their travel
plans
our vehicle is full of camping equipment
which supports uh what i said about how
we're going to our private land to train
which is our second amendment right so
todd
what kind of training are they doing and
you know they seem to
both cite the constitution and then kind
of claim they're not really
beholden to any laws that
are passed constitutionally so it's a
very it's a very odd dynamic they're
kind of picking and choosing
what they will be held accountable by
and two
and that's the argument they say that
they're not that they are
not anti-government but to chris's point
they
skirt around with their language their
ideology
they will make reference to that they
are independent of the law
not anti-government to me if you're not
following the laws of the us
then you're anti-government but
regarding the
the ideology as they would speak to
traveling
they say it's their god-given right to
travel that's why they don't need
driver's licenses
so again they split hairs they find this
way to manipulate words and make the
words
basically justify their actions what
we're seeing
with the social media the flag and all
these different things
this is going to be a propaganda
recruitment tool so they're absolutely
going to use and leverage
this to gain other other people in
interest now we don't know how many
are out there there are conflicting
numbers but watch and see
the the level of interest that this most
recent incident over the weekend will
gain
the the attention for the rise of the
moors well chris we've
we've heard a lot from our fbi director
christopher wray and from the attorney
general of the united states merrick
garland about the
growing white supremacist threat in the
united
states growing domestic terror threat i
never heard these guys mention and yet
in daytona
a couple weeks ago in florida a black
paramilitary
individual shot and killed a daytona
police officer
uh it does this doesn't kind of fit the
narrative of
charlottesville or or the white
supremacist
you know and and everything that they
obsess on uh
so why aren't we really understanding
more about them and why isn't the
the federal government speaking out
about this yeah as you mentioned i mean
they're they they present a danger to
law enforcement they don't recognize any
authority but yet
they're not recognized as extremists
even the southern poverty law center
backed off on that
they they had them classified as a
sovereign nation and and almost almost a
domestic terrorist group
but they backed off on that and just
said their anti-government
i don't know why you know it doesn't cut
it doesn't cut both ways it should
this is a black extremist group
primarily and we can we can just come
out and say that
i mean they they don't recognize any
authority i really think they're more
criminal organizations than they are
political ideological based i think they
use that to justify their crimes because
that's pretty much all they do
todd chris very interesting thank you so
much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else